my name's wreckit-ralph thirty years
I've been doing this it starts to feel
hard to love your job when no one else
seems to like you for doing it I play
Ralph he's kind of the bad guy in this
video game called fix-it Felix jr. which
is similar in some ways to Donkey Kong
where you're trying to go up this
structure and someone's trying smash
things on top of you anyway it's a
really popular game and I'm the bad guy
for thirty years in the game and then I
started having this midlife crisis and
decided to leave the game and I want
people to like me I want to be you know
like Michael Jordan when he decided he
didn't want to be a basketball player
anymore he wanted to be a baseball
player like the whole world went what
what are you doing like you're the
greatest space basketball player ever
anyway so that's what sort of happens
with my guy and he goes off and goes
into these other video games in the
arcade which is forbidden
among video game characters to cross
that line and one of the games I go into
is called sugar rush and it's like a
racing game with candy cars and there's
a sweet little girl well she's kind of a
bratty little girl actually played by
Sarah who I meet and then we kind of go
off on our journey together
game called sugar rush and she wants to
race but they won't let her because
she's a glitch and in a way she kind of
almost like The Wizard of Oz you know
here is wreck-it ralph who who wants so
much to not be a bad guy anymore and
this girl who doesn't want to be a
glitch and you kind of realize that
you're a lot in life isn't always your
destiny of it you know sometimes your
shortcomings can be it's like a behind
the scenes look at what video game
characters are like and what their
off-screen life is like and the things
they struggle with as video game
characters you know so I think it's for
like a wide span of ages because you
know even someone at our age it's like a
movie about behind you know the
after-hours life of the characters I
think what makes the movie original is
that unlike a movie like Toy Story where
you're introduced to this universe of
the toys and the rules of their kind of
world in this movie you're introduced to
one video game which is one reality for
this guy wreck-it Ralph and you see not
only what the game looks like from the
outside but what it looks like from the
inside but then he leaves that game and
goes into these other games so there's a
whole new universe and a whole new set
of rules that apply in each of those
places
I think it's classic buddy you know it's
like and you see this unlike this two
people who are very who do not like each
other at first and find out that they
they love each other
it's kind of like the big lumbering
older brother and the bratty little
sister who wants to come everywhere with
him it's a tale as all this time